a former congresswoman from new mexico
called deb
holland is joe biden's incoming
secretary of the interior and that's not
a small job make fun of it if you will
but the interior department manages
about a fifth
of the entire surface area of the united
states it's got 70
000 employees and an enormous budget
so it's a lot of power to run it what
does deb holland plan to do with all
this new power
well no one's asked her they're too busy
celebrating what she looks like
congresswoman deb holland appearing
before senators for her confirmation
hearing today
she would make history as the first
native american cabinet secretary if she
is confirmed
she would be the first native american
cabinet secretary if confirmed she is a
historic pick in this respect
she is going to be the first native
american to serve in this role
the interior department of course
governs public lands tribal lands
and so this is going to be a very
exciting pick for many democrats
it's very exciting that deb holland is a
native american that's cnn's position
they don't explain why it's exciting but
it's a good question why is it exciting
none of us choose how we were born it's
nothing that we did or that we earned
so it seems a little weird to be quote
excited about an accident of
birth how excited would cnn be if deb
holland were
unusually tall or had red hair was born
left-handed
the good news for deb holland is since
she was born the way that she was
no one is allowed to criticize her as
msnbc has explained
well they're desperate to launch a
counter-attack against
the democratic president at this point
attacking any old thing will do
but we're also talking about republicans
here so the go-to
is the same go to as usual pick out the
women and the people of color and just
go off
and so several republicans have decided
to target biden's
cabinet nominees of color like deb
holland
so that's who deb holland is she's a
person of color the most important thing
about deb holland is her ethnicity
that's the unanimous message from our
professional class
but since we're playing identity
politics here which obviously is
disgusting we wish we weren't identity
politics is stupid and immoral but since
we are
it's fair to ask a few more questions
deb holland identifies as a native
american
on the other hand holland sounds very
much like a scandinavian name and that
stuck
out to some of us who have scandinavian
names so what's going on here
well in fact deb holland is every bit as
much scandinavian as she is american
indian her father was norwegian
and that means in addition to everything
else deb holland is america's
first norwegian american interior
secretary since thomas cleppy
served in the ford administration almost
50 years ago
in their quiet brooding way the
scandinavian community we can tell you
is beaming with pride finally one of
ours has made it
little girls with names like larson and
hanson and doll
will watch cabinet meetings on c-span
and know that they too
have a chance to oversee one-fifth of
the american land mass someday
when deb holland speaks she'll be
speaking for millions of norwegian
americans
people whose ancestors have been here in
the americas for more than a thousand
years
their voices can now be heard deb
holland hero to the nordic people
she's welcome in our sauna anytime